well i do have something for you guys
that i think you're gonna for the this
is for the ladies because
you know we do a lot of stuff for guys
here and it's i would say most the
majority of our fan base is men you know
why do we have women but
guys we like to have a lot of fun about
here but i'd like to talk about
something serious black people
they're no laughing matter
you know the fbi says
[Laughter]
the fbi says 37 calls about a kid in
florida who wants to keep his school
why waste the gas now ricky vaughn
let's take that guy [ __ ] down to
prison under the jail
let's take him down
all right uh oh god you should dude yeah
royce showed me this this weekend i was
howling laughing i
i was i i couldn't
so uh kade
mr mr our favorite person in the world
uh
mr dayton hypernova uh starting a tinder
account finally
on a level of effort anyway so this is
him starting his
tinder account it's pretty nice right
why would he put like i love that he
just posts his number
he posts his info like he literally
puts a screenshot of his phone number
which
by the way not even you don't even need
that
to post the status and go like well i'm
on tinder and he posts the [ __ ]
oh no i didn't catch that mic holy [ __ ]
post this phone number like here's
here's a screenshot of my phone number
yeah like why would you do that
oh no no
look this isn't me boxing anybody this
is public you put this out it's
i want to point that out and i have two
phones like i have two phones i have two
phone numbers right
and i have my phone that like royce has
and my family has
like people that need to get in touch
with me and i have a [ __ ] phone that
has like i'd pay for very little service
on
but it's like my it's my phone that i
can afford to have doxxed and stuff
but even when i screenshot something and
it has my
my [ __ ] phone number on it i still
blur out like the last
four numbers just in case you know what
i mean
what an idiot what a [ __ ] idiot he is
what an idiot
i'm sorry the person you were oh well
should we left should we leave we should
have left a message okay you know what
let's try this again
um oh and it is his correct phone number
i could tell you that from first
i'm sorry the person you are trying to
reach has a voicemail box that has not
been set up yet
please try your call again later now
didn't set up his voicemail
damn it he never set up his voicemail i
wanted to do the phrase the pace
damn it hey look we tried so don't say
we didn't try
uh he then posted this
uh oh uh oh he wrote
oh my god i've been on tinder less than
an hour and i immediately found this
girl and we matched
this seems rare to me i don't have luck
on these sites but her blue outfit omg
is literally almost the same as the one
i saw christina ricci wears
recently it's similar to uh
some of the ruffle fringe ones i have as
well
same age as me and looks incredible
let's see
let's see what uh what he wrote for her
this is this is not by the way
as soon as you sent me that and i looked
at that picture i was like oh no
oh no it's like when you're when you're
on any of these sites there's one
that like if you if you have a sharp eye
you can spot them right away there's
certain ones where you go that one's
fake
and this one's clearly fake uh
so this one this he also then he wrote
this
uh i really love your fashion sense i
immediately was in awe of your blue
outfit
i have some with similar ruffles i can't
i can't i can't keep reading this mike
he can't do it do you want me yes please
i can't
can i do it i'm gonna read it as dayton
though okay okay
i really love your fashion sense i
immediately in all of your blue outfit
i have some similar raffle style anyway
i know tinder isn't a fashion networking
site
but i'm on here to date or meet like
wanted cisgender women
who like self-identifying trans lesbians
by the way
before i finish reading this
if you're a trans lesbian right
and you're not willing to date other
trans lesbians
aren't you transphobic like isn't that
i'm doing the math in my head you're
insisting that you're a woman
and that i have to identify you and
address you as a woman or i'm
transformed you're a woman right
but you're clearly also saying i only
like women
cisgender naturally born women so i'm
not attracted to
other trans lesbians you're right
only real women but then isn't that
aren't you being
trans like if you notice a lot of these
trans people don't want to date
other trans people they want a real
chick like
doesn't that tell you that maybe your
whole your
trans nonsense your this gobbledygook
that you believe in might just be fake
oh and then uh goes on i'm going into
phil oh he's going into filmmaking now
i'm going into filmmaking this year
after investing the past few
investing yeah investing i eat him so
much
investing the past few years in quirky
unique in flamboyant fashion
let's talk it's a it's a hell of a pitch
well uh miami mill says ah yes the
ladies love
when they can share outfits with their
boyfriends is that true do women like
that
uh then one more thing here which is
uh my favorite prick i uploaded a tinder
this is the one
this is the one this is the this i want
to know the ones that didn't make the
cut i need to see the other ones
looking good i totally
do have david bowie's irises in my eyes
very different size iris and people in
each one by the way you know it's good
you know you know things are going well
when you're when you're
when you're [ __ ] one of your defining
beautiful features is your irises yep
uh this is ivory's calling
uh his eye condition was permanent from
injury when someone was beating him
during his uh pre-adolescence
mine seems to happen on days i don't
stress i don't
get nearly enough sleep living where i'm
stressed often so he thinks he's the
same per yes
um no i'm just i'm curious are you sure
that's when it happened
and not when he was teenagers
because i was just curious um oh i don't
know that's something disappointing
uh david bowie did in fact
teenagers maybe that's when his eyes got
[ __ ] up
are you sure i just want to know was it
an accident or was it when he was
teenagers i think it happened when he
was dancing in the street ah with mick
jagger yeah mick jagger accidentally
did like this yeah and he poked him
right in the eye yeah and then he went
on a
teenager okay okay that's also true yes
[Music]
can't argue that cannot argue that she's
just doing the norm mcdonald thing now
where there's no punchline
no you know yeah teenagers